ihre hände waren auf dem rücken
gefesselt mit einem knoten wie in die
sadomaso szene benutzt an ihren füßen
eine schwere gehwegplatte so wurde sie
in die villa geworfen und das noch
lebendig andrea gerade mal 19 jahre alt
qualvoll ertrunken ermordet ende april
wurde ihre leiche bei nienburg in
niedersachsen aus dem kalten fluss
gezogen jetzt endlich steht der fall vor
der aufklärung
nach bild-informationen ist dieser
zuhälter nun in haft
stefan k er soll andrea in die weser
geworfen haben um sie ohne jede spur
loszuwerden offenbar weil sie aussteigen
wollte als prostituierte
doch wie bild erfuhr wollte er andrea zu
saramago praktiken zwingen wollte sie
einem anderen zuhälter abkaufen
diego de bisher stand der alleine unter
tatverdacht
nun gehen die ermittler davon aus dass
auch stefan k diesen brutalen mord
begangen hat seit heute nun sitzt der
zuhälter in untersuchungshaft für diesen
so grausamen prostituierten mord in der
weser bild reporter stephan siewering
recherchiert in diesem fall stefan was
wissen wir noch genaueres über die
verdächtigen in diesem schrecklichen
mordfall
es ist nur der de kuka der dvd war der
freund von der andrea er hat sie zur
prostitution gezwungen und offenbar gab
es streitigkeiten sie hat ihm geld
geklaut und so und er wollte sie
loswerden
so wie es heißt wollte sie verkaufen an
denen stefan k an weiteren zuhälter der
aus dem sado maso mir kommt und
möglicherweise das ist jetzt ein
bisschen vermutung wollte sie das nicht
hat dann gesagt nee es gab streit und
vielleicht hat sie gedroht hier ich lass
euch aufs fliegen und dann soll wohl ein
gemeinschaftlicher mord begangen worden
sein so sieht es die staatsanwaltschaft
und es sinnvoll auch die beiden jetzt in
u haft gekommen
durch welche und so gewinnt denn die
behörden den beiden jetzt auf die spur
gekommen und ja offensichtlich so
konkret dass sie jetzt in
setzen also sie hatten den dialog der
schon lange auf vermutet dass er der
mörder ist konnte ihm das aber nicht
nachweisen
auch dieser stefan k war schon drei
wochen lang haben im gespräch aber die
entscheidenden spuren zählten zuletzt
wurden 5000 euro belohnung ausgesetzt
damit möglicherweise jemand außerdem
profitiert milieu erzählt möglicherweise
kam der entscheidende hinweis jetzt
daher
es wurde beim nachbarn von stefan k an
der fehlt wohl eine gehwegplatte im
garten und möglicherweise hat er ist aus
dieser db gehwegplatte mit der jetzt die
andrea versenkt wurde
das müsste jetzt geprüft werden es ist
ein gutachter dabei zu prüfen ob das die
debatte ist die ece saarland stefan
sievering mit informationen zu diesem
prostituierten fall dort an der weser
ganz herzlichen dank für deine
information